c'est la mesure phare pour pour nous
c'est sans doute là la fiscalité la plus
injuste aujourd'hui cette fiscalité sur
sur le carburant pour tous nos
compatriotes qui travaillent en général
les gens qui utilisent voiture au gasoil
pour aller travailler qui font 40
kilomètres pour aller travailler
c'est pas les plus aisés et les plus
modestes au contraire souvent ils n'ont
pas de moyen de transport de
substitution
donc quand vous passez d'un plein à 65
euros à 100 euros ces 35 euros par plein
si vous en faites trois et demi dans le
moi ça veut dire 120 euros
la question c'est la méthode vous dites
qu'on baisse la taxe est un carburant
est ce qu on sait combien ça coûte alors
il ya plusieurs idées plusieurs taxes
sur les carburants c'est vers le chenal
c'était une première tva il ya là des
icpe il ya une deuxième tva au total
aujourd'hui quand on prend un plein de
trophées un plein de carburant mais pour
moitié le coût c'est des tacles plus de
la moitié rien plus de prendre 55 et 60%
selon selon le prix du du baril va être
est un peu technique alors ça coûte en
réalité ça dépend ça dépend de la du
cours du cours du baril ce que de tonga
notamment et et fluctue mais ce qui est
anormal souhait c'est quand même que la
que l'état s'enrichissent sur le dos des
français